born and raised say it's a home away
from home it's for sure it's a Local's
favorite and they just opened their
third location in North Las Vegas here
to tell us more his owner Scottie godino
Jr and kitchen manager Reuben Chavez
welcome to the show thank you for having
us it's great to have you guys back in
studio congratulations on the new
location what makes this new location
different than the other two
um well we've been open for 12 years now
it's kind of a 2.0 version elevating
what we've already set before new
features on the menu within the space
we've come up with the coin wall to
honor Nellis just some really cool
different features that get to kind of
take you throughout and come
compartmentalized experience let's break
that down because you're so close new
location is so close to Nellis what is
this coin wall because you're honoring
our military people here in town what's
the coin wall uh uh all armed forces are
awarded a coin wall or a coin that has
what they're servicing in
um so all the men and women that protect
us and sacrifice is what they do for us
every day we feature their coins on a
wall that we then give them our coin
that we made it gives them 50 off we
feature and Champion what they've done
for us on a daily basis I love that
you're you're watching out for our
military here in Las Vegas because your
grandfather was military correct yes he
was in World War II and uh got blown up
on Normandy but survived and got a
Purple Heart oh my God amazing amazing
okay well you have here one of your
signature dishes what do you have in
front of us so this right here we have
chicken peppers onions along with
tequila sauce the main ingredient soy
sauce cilantro and onions now Reuben is
this your favorite dish this is my
favorite dish atheists at least twice a
week and I love it too born and raised
you're born here in Las Vegas a local
spot and how long have you been with
born and raised ten years
congratulations 10 year anniversary can
I try some of that over there and as far
as just scooping in here as far as
cocktails is there a go-to go-till
cocktail we should try perfect we've got
Huckleberry lemonade here
um sugar rim it's fresh blueberries
strawberries some other fun stuff in
there to drink
we've got uh where's the other one
what's that one that's that one
especially cocktails hey football
football this weekend right playoff
games you have all the games and
everything yeah we do absolutely um and
we've got a 160 inch projection screen
that we bring down for all the games
nights Games Etc it is so good and you
guys Third location born and raised
continuing to grow though there's a
fourth one coming yeah Centennial and
Durango we'll uh start to take over our
TI's in March you kidding me with this
oh always smokes that are so delicious
Scotty thank you thank you for having me
that is amazing give me the recipe hi
girls